well check this out when it comes time I
do not believe you will see random anti
file roaming the suburbs I believe you
will see the people who are in the Armed
Forces or police police department and
what someone gonna do when a cop shows
up like you got a look at what happened
in Venezuela Cuba the Soviet Union okay
you did have in history in the Spanish
Civil War
you did have factions fighting each
other in the streets but what I think is
a really I don't act like it's it's it's
super likely because you know who knows
what's gonna happen it's it's it's it's
easy to make claims it's hard to know
for sure I want to know what what to do
though saying that listen you know what
your the point of the price of freedom
is high is not an answer you know like
what what do people do what can they do
right now protest so he's fully
law-abiding peacefully go out and
protest link arms darting statues don't
bring weapons and then when the video
cameras start rolling and it shows you
know a middle-aged Latino mom saying
please stop being beaten by an tyfa that
might suck for that woman for sure
because I've been in that situation what
do you think people and look look what
happen when Andino got beaten by an tyfa
you remember this mmm that was a
nightmare scenario for the far-left
a gay vietnamese child of immigrants was
brutally beaten in the streets while he
could even fight back yeah and everyone
turned they were you know they tried
smearing they tried slamming him but boy
it was not working it was a bad bad show
for them well that happened in Chad's
like three days ago it was I mean not as
it's not that it's prominent as a Nino
but it was a Japanese reporter yep he
was four black lives matter going into
to show how peaceful it was and they
they beat him out they'd be the crap out
of him yeah they did it's like but then
he came out still in favor of them and
he was an American how because it's it's
a cult man no no I know
I know actually why because the that's
what I said earlier there's a difference
between the people who are peacefully
protesting and the people who are not
there that are trying to take a hold of
it and steer it down a different Street
to my power
exactly here's what I see happening if
you get a bunch of regular people
middle-aged men and women
and they show up around a Columbus
statue and they link arms that's it a
statue will not come down the statue
will not come down but no one will do
that it's a peaceful assembly its
law-abiding yeah and then the issue for
these local politicians like Cuomo is
that they're looking at what's happening
and they see large loud angry activist
base destroying things and no one else
cares so they say hey look if the only
people who care are the ones burning
everything the ground I guess this is
what it is that's who's gonna vote for
me so that I'll give them what they want
so it's all you got to do and and guess
what these people are violent these
people may bring weapons you might get
hit but you have to be peaceful and it
and it works and and and then the left
only what doesn't because they're but
they're wrong there wasn't wrong they've
weaponized victimhood to an extreme
degree they know exactly why peaceful
protest works they know that when the
video comes out of the cop dragging the
protester away they win sympathy that's
what they've been doing the entire time
this is what I've been telling people is
when you look it to the to the extreme
right there it's a high intensity
extreme moment where one person commits
an atrocity and it shocks and terrifies
everyone what an tyfa and far leftist do
is low-grade terrorism where they'll hit
you one time and no one cares that it
happened yeah but then when you fight
back they cower and shake and go and
when the cops move in to make arrests
they're going hope help and the videos
come out and they go look what's
happening to us we're being repressed I
think that's what Chaz was I think Chaz
was a big ploy to try to get Trump to
bring in the army and they will shut him
down and they would have been like this
is what we're talking about a male would
have sewn yeah exactly the mayor was
like it was our Summer of Love what was
she doing oh people were getting shot
and they can't handle it anymore take
the bait so they took Chaz down the the
mayor asked them they were like going
around like all right we're gonna
peacefully leave thanks everybody
is that what happened yes after four
shootings it's just like really hmm
you want to know what you need to do is
I don't think I wasn't telling people
and I hope people realize just just to
arbitrarily be like I quit for no reason
right now but but to actively protest if
they made you do something you didn't
want to do if they were like we want you
where this you know this this symbol on
your vest oh no that's basically what it
was right
like you have to conform yeah okay no
I'm not doing that and then I got fired
and then when you when that when you
hear like right now we're hearing that
they're gonna go tear down the statue of
Lincoln where is that no that DC no I
don't know but I know that there's this
whole anti fuh flag burning ceremony
that's supposed to happen July 4th in
Gettysburg so that's really not very far
from me maybe we should go there and do
a live show the flag burning yeah oh my
I don't think I don't think they would
like seeing either of us there I think
you and I are both our target to them to
who the people want to burn a Depot
flags
no no aunty fuh is showing us to burn
American flags you want to still want to
go no I didn't think so
no no I thought you meant that the right
was gonna burn a flag no no no they're
meeting in Gettysburg because that's one
of the largest battles that I've fought
for this country I know a little
somethin at this level nonsense and July
4th pretty big day for us I don't know
if you you know about that I'm excited
4th of July but look I'll say it one
more time just to cuz I really want to
drive it home yeah all it takes is for
you to show up no shields no weapons no
helmets nothing and link arms and you
know might happen you will get an D node
they won't they will throw milkshakes in
your face they will punch you you'll be
left bleeding and then the entire media
will be alike why would these local
residents begging these extremists to
stop being brutally beaten while they
didn't fight back yeah this is what
people don't understand about perception
there's this famous comic that goes
around and it shows a circle and in it
you see what looks like a hand in a
knife and a person being shocked like
they're about to be stabbed and then the
bigger picture is a camera and it's
actually the night.the it's like the
knife is actually the foot of the person
running away and the person shocked is
the person actually reaching to stab
them meaning the framing of the camera
changed what you thought was happening
framings everything yeah certainly
learned that in the past couple months
so peaceful protests work 100% they
absolutely do work because you stay
within the confines of what's morally
acceptable and you become the victim and
this is why this one
got fired from his job they say this
they say this researcher tweeted out
from an african-american social
psychology professor I guess or whatever
says I don't know what his position was
that peaceful protests result in a
two-point swing and violent riots result
in a two-point drop for the party so
like did you specifically talking about
Democrats versus Republicans yeah excuse
me Edda Bert when people protests happen
positive coverage emerges and then the
the party that's peacefully protesting
gets a ton of attention talks about
their issues and they win over
supporters when the group gets violent
and destroys thing it swings in the
other way because they're the bad guys
now yeah so it's possible that an tyfa
has lost ton of favor because of the
violent riots but the media covered for
them the whole time saying peaceful
protesters they blamed the police for it
right so even here like look look at
this article wisconsin state senator
attacked by protestors seriously as
demonstrations in madison turned violent
no they they showed up to riot because
they were pissed that someone rightfully
got arrested for what he he didn't get
killed
he was arrested right and they ride and
just say things he was threatening
people the bat and on a private in a
private restaurant like and they were
told no he said you can't stop me I've
got a bat I'll try to stop me I dare you
it's like okay so now we're ending
people they arrest him what do you think
what's gonna happen what do think would
happen if fifty seventy year old little
grannies linked arms around a statue
they'd be the the bosses humans I've
ever I'd be willing to bet anti flow
wouldn't go anywhere near them and say
anything at all because they know some
somebody might they've attacked all
people in the past yeah but could you
imagine the cameras rolling and the
granny Brigade with like fresh fresh
cookies and little trays we're standing
around saying grandma grandma says no
violence and then they started whacking
old ladies okay so what just just real
quick we have an art contest going on
right now I want to see that protecting
statues with cookies giving them out and
Auntie foe just stand-in there listen
all right what are these continue what
you were saying about bait
Trump yeah is exactly it yeah they want
to trick you into getting violence so
they can use it against you yep when the
proud boys got into a fight in New York
they went to prison and the left was
like yes God we got ripped these people
into swinging the punch yeah and and now
we won it's so obvious what Chaz was
that's what it was yeah well everybody
we're they were trying to push like why
isn't Trump doing anything why isn't
Trump bringing this down it's like what
do you mean it's the state's thing you
just been drilling him for not doing
anything remove it and they're like no
we get to decide what we do with Kovac
cuz we're the states and then this
happened and they're like Trump why it's
like what no you're the state you deal
with it what
but Trump told the governor and the
mayor to get to deal with it right and
if it makes America look bad but they
mocked Trump for it and now for
shootings later yeah may was her name
Jenny Durkin or whatever he's like oh
well I mean you know it's like yeah
that's on you yeah you couldn't happen
at any point she could have stopped and
the poll said they were told to get out
yeah exactly what did you think was
gonna happen what do you think these
people some love and she walked that
back to like well really that sounds
like a horror film yeah it does I'm
gonna write a song called Summer of Love
oh good actually actually I'll back you
up on it I actually had a really good
idea for a song oh yeah I was inspired
you know that you know the sign said
long-haired freaky people need not apply
great song yeah it applies to me I was
thinking in that kind of upbeat kind of
vein and the normies said please just
leave me alone okay and so it can be the
song to be called Summer of Love and I
was thinking I'm in the early stages of
writing it works basically going through
all the crazy things that have been
escalating such a storyteller like yeah
all my songs are stories I know they're
so it's like you know first they said
you know don't don't insult me then they
say I'd use my pronouns then they said
we just want to add a character to your
video games and then it ends with then
they're in my home with a gun point in
my head and the nor me said please just
leave me alone yeah so it's like it
that's not a gunshot yeah it'll be
called the summer of love yet the summer
of love because it ends with them
surrounding your house and setting up an
autonomous zone where they start
demanding money from you and I say
here's the money but please just leave
me alone and they came in and stole my
food and ripped the ripped the copper
out of the walls to sell and I said yeah
you can take it but please just leave me
alone now at what point do these people
realize
they're literally not leaving you alone
yeah that's what's happening yep
well what trapped me take the bait so
what he didn't because he's actually
smart despite what everyone tries to
well not I don't want to say everyone
but the the Democrats meaning our left
doesn't know I know it is it's it's up
in the air right now but Iran know who
I'm voting for the New York Times did a
they released their poll Biden fifty
Trump thirty six and I keep hearing from
any of everybody yeah the polls are
wrong the media is wrong and I'm like
well Hillary had a 97% chance to win 87
know the day before I saw I saw I looked
into it it's like the day before it was
in November second and she had a 97%
chance to win I was like oh wow she lost
the New York Times yeah but that's
that's probability not polls okay so the
New York Times released an explainer
talking about how they did their polling
and they said that even though they
predicted Hillary would win Trump was
still in the correct national popular
vote margins yeah but we look about
right now the temperature in America and
imagine and people are being ostracized
from groups for saying I'm a trump
supporter like someone called you said
yourself somebody calls you up said who
you vote for I'm gonna vote for button
click I'm voting for Trump you know it
could be or it could course they're
gonna say buy it and I won't tell
anybody that they're voting for Trump
it's like but think about the simple
solution here what we are saying there
must be so the simple solution is the
polls got released yeah I'm pissed
losing okay is it now we are trying to
justify how that could possibly be right
but that's not what's being presented to
us so it could be irrational of us to
try and justify why Trump really is
doing better well maybe it's good though
because you said it's like if if they
think he's gonna lose they're gonna show
up it's a it's actually when I'm yes yes
and no if you think you're gonna lose
completely don't bother so it's a mix of
I think Trump's gonna lose but he has a
chance I don't have you seen like Trump
rallies the people that show up they're
there they're not gonna get disheartened
there's they're gonna rally he didn't
have his million people in Tulsa listen
listen you could make every excuse in
the book for why people didn't show up
oh but 13 plus you know 13 or so million
watched online so
huge number are not online but remotely
it's true
but if people aren't willing to actually
get up and go support the president in
person okay then maybe they won't be
willing to do it in November I think for
look I think the people that didn't show
up there's a lot of this kovat thing
people are still afraid of it's like if
they keep shoving it down your throat
they're not gonna show up for the
Democrats either it's not like it's only
the Republicans who are afraid of that
it's like everyone I feel what did you
just tell me about ballots popping up
with only Democratic votes on them
that's exactly it
I'm it's not just one source I'm it's
popping up but I'm seeing as I pull it
up okay what's going on here pull it up
read that one man the New Jersey WN w a
NW ACP says leader calls for Paterson
mail-in vote to be canceled amid
corruption claims so we have proof that
there's corruption in mail and voting
this is just one story man and I'm
pretty sure it's a blue state isn't it
yeah it's a blue state funny you should
say that I I've seen a lot a lot when I
say this I mean a lot over 300 easy
comments of people talking about how
they're their dead loved ones voted
Democrat that they were like yeah I my
mother's been dead for ten years and I
just got this thing that she voted
Democrat I don't know who elections
how about check this up I don't want to
name the person so if you know the name
please don't say well okay but we got a
mail-in ballot to this house really we
did okay I didn't I really I got an
application for a mail-in ballot find a
ballot came oh man I just let it out
love a good sneeze no I love a good
sneeze sneezing feels so good it's it's
basically your body getting rid of an
irritant that's that's literally what a
sneeze is so yes I could resistance was
futile yeah listen listen we got a
mail-in ballot here yeah and I was
shocked when it came Wow I was like woah
woah woah what I don't know why is this
here yeah what and then I said where the
where's the rest of the mail-in ballot
with people in house right don't have
them we got a few no we know we don't
know you're wrong
we got applications for ballots we got
applications for ballots meaning I can
fill it out and then ask for one and
it's it's shocking because it seems like
there's no time for that to actually
happen right yeah why did why did this
one come for somebody who's not here I
don't know I don't like it it's fishy I
don't like the system and I don't miss
them anymore I mail a mail-in ballot
came here for someone who does not live
here right and how hard would it be for
some person to just like this person's
voting for me well that's the jersey man
yeah and that's just one state that's a
blue state and listen I chose this story
for a reason and double-a-c-p leader has
canceled the vote that's not that's not
that's not a Republican no no no that's
not a Republican that the Democrat and
320 20 percent of the vote was voided
that's crazy
Wandy percent it's insane that's a lot
so I tell you what man when I hear from
my friends they're saying things like
you know make voting easier yeah we need
to get email and voting and I'm like you
can't just say things okay I understand
your point but now we're looking at an
entire group of black voters completely
disenfranchised yep by your progressive
policies Oh
Democrats hmm Democrats trying to took
control home you're being racist here's
the simple example that I give to people
so they can understand the problem with
surface-level solutions let's say
there's a protester in the street just
one
okay told me little signs saying banned
cilantro and you're like it's a
ridiculous cause it's stupid
this is ridiculous right but you hate
cilantro don't you I hate it so wouldn't
you at least applaud a little bit I'd be
like yeah brother
some people are sitting there going like
rock on brother cilantro is nasty yeah
but but traffic is blocked up around a
long ways because he's stand in the
middle street so the cops walk up and
they said we gotta clear the street yo
buddy move he says no I have a First
Amendment right to peacefully some piece
of lead assemble okay the cops say if
you don't move you'll be arrested the
cop thinks we got a clue the traffic the
easy way to do it just arrest the guy
well obstructing vehicular traffic is
actually a misdemeanor right so the cop
says
the easiest way to deal with this right
now is to just arrest the guy yeah and
he does and tomorrow there's ten
protesters police brutality grows these
nasty cops violated our rights then the
cops come out and they put on shields
this time and they go start start
smacking heads and locking these people
up the next day a hundred protesters
show up okay
the simple solution in this to this
problem seems just arrest them and
they're done and then you incite more
protests so I'm not saying that's you
know you never stop the protesters you
never arrest them I'm saying right
you've got to think about what happens
and how you how you engage so if Trump
for instance came out to Chaz with you
know APCs and soldiers right he would
have made it a hundred times worse
you're right
he sat back yeah and they let themselves
up and now the mayor looks like an idiot
it's true so so I bring this up because
the people who are all screaming for
mail-in voting are the cops saying the
easiest way to get rid of protesters to
arrest him the easiest way to get people
to vote is just send him a ballot it's
like and then you open the door to the
whole thing being bunk yeah so buddy but
think about it we talked about Democrats
and Republicans claiming the victory on
both sides right yeah so what happens if
they decide to go mail and voting and
then in Newark New Jersey yeah
50,000 mail and votes are avoided you
know oh the whole the whole election is
Trump then win turns out they're all
Republican votes too they just voided
the Republican votes the Democrats are
all in it's not what I mean though I
know I'm just right adding a layer of
conspiracy from Trump wins a resounding
victory he wins you know 500 electoral
votes and then the Democrats find one
state where the mail-in vote is is
broken yeah and they say we have to
avoid the whole election look look at
the state the whole thing's corrupt if
this one's bad they're all bad and they
refuse to accept it now to be fair it
would have to be a close race Trump wins
but then they find one suspicious state
and it goes the Supreme Court yeah
and the Supreme Court says even though
Trump won the electoral college and the
popular vote this fraud means the
Democrats win everything and then the
Supreme Court sides the Democrats and
Trump gets told easily he's a loser even
though he actually won yeah then what
happens
maybe not what I mean ah maybe but I'm
just entertaining what are conservatives
and moderates linking hands and guarding
statues are our moderates look at the
the black lives matter guy who got fired
from Taco Bell and then look at the
Trump supporters outside of the
convention who were told to leave
because of curfew or they said you got a
boss and they swapped away now the next
day they got rid of the curfew for sure
but I don't I I never see conservatives
go out and protest or moderates go out
and protest it's always the far left in
fact Democrats won't move out in protest
and they do sometimes yeah it's mostly
the extremists and then they win every
single time I read a story I read a
story on Twitter today where there was a
left-wing activists like a social
justice warrior who quit her job because
her boss made like a racist or sexist
joke and I was like if this leftist can
quit her job on the spot because the
joke hurt her feelings then why can you
not consider taking steps to make your
voice heard in a principled way at your
job without freaking out about it why
would you not even consider this I got I
gotta say man the left has it's part of
their temper tantrum but you gotta
understand what temper tantrum is lack
of emotional intelligence the
willingness and demand and refuse to
compromise competence a temper tantrum
is the unwillingness to compromise
that's true
it's the toxic version of it yeah
rolling on the ground screaming
demanding but guess what it's working
well this is what I was saying earlier
about how society is coddled us we're
we're spoiled we we have everything and
a lot of us appreciate it
but a lot of people have no idea thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you